hey guys how you doing
good morning hi morgan hello um so
i started watching
the season four at like one in the
morning i was just like kind of getting
it in i was so excited to watch it and i
was terrified i didn't know it was gonna
be so scary which was so fun joe on a
scale of one to ten how scared do you
think season four is
uh i would say
it's probably at nine
just so we can leave a little room for
next year i guess but it's definitely
scary yeah it's definitely scary were
you surprised that it got so dark
i was yeah the the um
you know i this show is for everyone you
know that's something i love about the
shows for you know parents and kids and
so it definitely is going to scare some
children
i love i mean it scared me um maya it
was so fun you know last season seeing
the the friendship grow between robin
and steven this season we're definitely
seeing a fun friendship with nancy and
robin why do you think this dynamic is
so entertaining to watch
because it's kind of another odd couple
a couple like a stranger things kind of
notorious odd couple where it's like oh
we take these two people with these
really different characteristics and
then they kind of find common ground and
i think that's like a really beautiful
uh
like theme of the show uh and i i think
that it's just
an amazing
team and they also kind of really bring
a lot of the planning
uh and to the to the environment uh of
the show
and i don't know it's just i think it's
just great
yeah
no i i yeah i agree
yeah and what was it like just working
together on so many fun scenes together
we like each other yeah we do yeah
we enjoy
yeah there's some really fun days
um
yeah no maya's really fun to play off of
it's really just
a fun character
i love the chemistry so i'm putting this
out into the universe i want a nancy
wheeler detective style spin-off series
i feel like this can happen
if you were going to pick a stranger
things character to be your sidekick on
this new show who would you pick
wow
um
i mean
wow
maya's like america i mean i think nancy
and robin
thing would be fun i think they've got
such a good
soap matter like yeah i don't know i
think it's just really interesting you
know it's very different dynamics like
all the president's men or something
i'm saying we can work with hopper at
the police station good cop detectives
yeah
please make this happen um
i know joe with your character steve
obviously always complaining about being
the babysitter which we love watching so
much but you get to be a bit of an
action hero this season
was that fun
it's fun yeah it feels like uh
yeah i mean to also to you know read the
scripts at the table reading to see all
this the scope of the whole thing and
the stuff that you'll get to do i yeah i
really enjoyed it but
it feels like everybody i mean everybody
gets a little piece of action you know
every this this season
and i imagine next season as well has
just kind of grown and scoped and you
know all these different storylines
taking place in all these various
locations
definitely fun i guess is the long
answer
no no i love it and joseph joseph what's
it like for you you know obviously these
guys have known each other for three
seasons now you come on board it's one
of the you know most popular shows ever
and you just have fit and seamlessly
you're so great this season what's it
been like for you
oh thank you
uh what's it been it's been kind of
weird and
great
obviously i think the timing was quite
odd
like kind of
during the pandemic so that was quite um
kind of peculiar
um but
it was a great experience they were
wonderful people and so brilliant at
their jobs i think kind of what i
didn't really realize kind of because
yeah i hadn't worked on it yet was kind
of how much they bring to their
characters and how much trust the duffer
brothers have in them to kind of color
it in and kind of add those little bits
of detail um so they were um yeah just
it was a it was a treat
well congratulations on the season you
guys uh it's uh it's really good it's
really dark i love it so freddy
krueger's house very good
yes cool thank you thank you
you